sparks are flying at the huber plant in
regensburg even though there has been a
decrease in orders the mechanical
engineering company employs around one
thousand workers
the manager expanded business with
russia planning on long-term growth of
10 percent
the one factor not included in his
growth calculations the ukrainian
conflict
the crisis has led to a 30 depreciation
of the ruble over the last 12 months
and that's made our products more
expensive in russia
we've had to postpone projects and
renegotiate certain deals already signed
we want to see this crisis through with
our long-term customers
uber makes pipes filters and entire
systems for the wastewater industry
its customers include public and private
utility companies many in the us where
the economy is on the up
management is uncertain if orders from
russia dry up permanently will the
company have to reduce its workforce
we'll keep our team on board so that
we're ready when the situation improves
right now however we have to trade very
carefully and avoid new investments
we have to wait and see how the
political situation develops over there
the companies operating there have no
influence
if anyone knows how german companies are
faring it's the etho research institute
in munich
analyst klaus vollrabber says the
business climate is far from sunny he
cites the growing number of crisis
hotspots around the world coupled with a
drop in domestic demand in the eurozone
the experts we asked in all countries
expect the current business situation
has if anything gotten worse as has the
outlook for the next six months
among the few glimmers of hope are spain
and portugal they're doing slightly
better although they are emerging from a
steep downturn so the prospects for the
eurozone are not too good
nonetheless there are plenty of
businesses in germany and elsewhere
doing quite well
the mood at this recent industrial
machinery trade fair in munich was
certainly upbeat german exports surged
in september to a record monthly high
it's interesting to hear this constant
talk of the economy slacking
we see no sign of that
there's uncertainty because there's so
little information from the car industry
but we reckon the market will be
relatively healthy next year
a milling machine like this can cost up
to two million euros it's the kind of
major investment that requires careful
consideration by a company
the machine is made by the zimmermann
company based outside stuttgart
they've had a good year are set to
expand and need a new production hall
they're determined to go ahead despite
concerns about rising energy costs and
the business climate in europe
when there are changes afoot you also
need to look at the context
and our level over the last two years
has been very high
so any minor changes in certain areas
are not a disaster
so not all companies in germany are
anxious about the future even if the
analysts cite figures that cast a shadow
over the country's economic outlook
you